بنظرات مملوءه بالشكل والحيره والازعاج
رامقتنا هذه القطه بعد ما اقتحمنا عالمها
في هذه السياره المتهلكه التي اتخذتها
منزلا
مئه الالاف من السيارات والمركبات
المتهلكه تملا شوارع العاصمه بل والمدن
المصريه تكفى لا تشكل ملاذا للقطط
والحيوانات فقط ولكنها تشكل خطوره امنيه
وبيئه غير امنه فضلا عن ازدحام الشوارع
بها
تجار المخدرات
في اي حاجه ما لهاش صاحب فضل ان لازم نعرف
مين عربيه مين دي مركونه بتاعه مين
ومركونه ليه وفين مشكلته هذه المركبات
المهمله ادت الى تدخل رئاسي لانهاء اشغال
الطرق بالسيارات والمركبات المهمله التي
تعيق مشاريع التطوير في البناء التحتيه
التي بدات هم مصر وتخفيف ازدحام الشوارع
فضلا عن تصفيه مقابر السيارات التي تضم
الاف السيارات المصادره في قضايا مختلفه
وتصنيف ما يمكن اعاده الاستفاده منه او
احالته الى التكهين
في كل محافظه هتلاقي في مقابر السيارات
يعني كان في كذا مقبره في القاهره على
سبيل المثال كانوا كبار جدا استفاده اللي
هترجع لنا من موضوع ان احنا هنقضي على
العربيات المتهلكه اللي موجوده دي العربيه
دي ما كانتش ما كانش فيه منها اي استفاده
لما يتم اعاده تدوير هذه السيارات ممكن
احنا بعد كده او تق قطع الغيار بتاعتها
احنا ممكن يتم عمل سكراب ياردس تبع
الحكومه او حتى يتم بيعها في مزادات قراره
التخلص من المركبات المتهلكه لا قطر حيبا
كبيرا العربيه دي هياخذوها تتركز المواتير
ديت بتتجمع كلها بيتعمل عليها مزاجات
متهلكه وبايظه ومركونه زباله والكلام ده
دي تتشال الاستفاده من المركبات المتاهه
ستنعكس ايجابيا بتخفيف الزحام الشوارع
فضلا عن اعاده التدوير والحصول على قطع
غيار مستعمله باسعار زهيده واسطه موجه
الغلاء الحاليه راندا ابو العزم العربيه
القاهره